i said to young people the millennials
you know you've been screwed
you know you're being left for the world
that's absolute horrible shape
financially and all this
student loan debt pensions are
collapsing
financial systems are collapsing the
rich are getting richer
but apparently somebody gave you
something
to get yourself out of this and what the
millennials have that i didn't have
was the iphone the iphone is the single
most powerful
i cannot believe how much power that
thing has
so it seems to me i'm not really
religious i'm not
not political but i'm saying that
god does provide at some level and god
provided the millennials with an iphone
holy mac all you have to do is sync your
brain to that iphone you have more power
than you and i ever had when we're at
their age you know you know what i mean
the trouble is if they don't haven't
gone to school and they have a teacher
that is incompetent and we've all had
income competent teachers
their brain and the iphone are not
synced into making money
do what i mean and if you can't make
money with your iphone there's something
wrong in your brain not the iphone
screen
i went to war twice on the front lines
yeah and i checked
what happened so i joined the marine
corps i got a flight full of pensacola i
learned to fly go to camp pendleton
i strap all my weapons i go to advanced
weapons and camp pendleton
i go to okinawa and then they send me
into vietnam
and i came out of vietnam about four
months later
back to back to restage in okinawa and i
thought everybody had changed
i looked at the fellow marines and i
thought
and it wasn't that they were i had been
to war
you got tougher it's different
when somebody's trying to kill you every
single mission i went down
three times no way yeah and i came back
stronger and tougher so i come back to
okinawa
i got like a week off and they're going
to ship me back into vietnam again i
said what happened to these guys
and it wasn't that they changed i
changed
so what happens to entrepreneurs who go
out and they get their ass handed to
them and they survive
if you survive you see the world
differently so that's what happened to
you when you get injured and all this
yeah
you see a different world whereas some
peace time
who's climbing the corporate ladder
right now they just lost their job
they're sucking their thumb you know
this is the worst time for them
yet for a wartime leader this guy
they're excited they're excited about it
yeah it's the best of times yeah if
you're an entrepreneur right now
the world's open to you you're an
employee your world's
dead to you well the japanese had a
thing called kumiyai
kumiyai was that if you lived in the
same neighborhood in hawaii and you live
you were japanese all the japanese stuck
together
and my father who was six foot four for
japanese was pretty big
the kumi would come and you know talk to
our family about the japanese sticking
together
my father threw them out and these are
other ja he says look
we're americans get that in your head
right now
you know so i had i had this conflicting
cultural values
sure sure so again for every
entrepreneur
first thing you must inspect is what was
your cultural heritage
nothing is right or wrong also if you
want to have more confidence self-love
self-belief check out my 254 series
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
so i've designed a special
free program to help you get it where i
will send you an unlisted video
to your email for the next 254 days to
shift
your self belief forward the link to
sign up for free
is in the description below i don't
cheat on my wife i don't cheat on my
customers
i don't cheat people i don't cut corners
if i can't do something i'll tell you up
front if i screw up i'll tell you
people always kind of dump on
what you call the fast food industry
if i had to do it again i could work for
mcdonald's look
i have a i have an unfair advantage you
know i went to war
and at war i'm alive because other guys
died for me
number one is investing is invest in
what you love i love
business i love real estate i mean i
really love it i own this building here
and i love gold and silver so i invest
in what i love
most people say you know and do what you
love but i rather invest in what i love
but i love being an entrepreneur
i love investing it's like shark tank to
me
i'm always looking at new businesses new
deals it's just a game like this
you know when you look at the financial
statement that's like your score card
it's like your golf scorecard is your
financial statement
but as you know our schools teach us
nothing about financial statements
that's why you know most guys was it
every most major league
athletes are broke within six years or
something they lose everything
sure or lottery winner yeah because
money never makes you rich
and so the thing is to invest in your
life experiences your mentors
so the story of rich dad poor dad is
choosing between two different teachers
you know if i followed my poor dad i'd
probably be a government employee in
hawaii
you know or a tenured teacher yeah so
it's it's a hard choice you gotta choose
your teachers wisely
i made a fortune in 2008. 2020
i'm making more money and paying less
taxes
it doesn't mean i don't have problems
but i'm prepared for this
my biggest problem right now is because
everybody's taking a vacation
i can't get enough product i'm selling
out you know my cash flow game
is sold out it's selling out
constantly all over the world all over
the world i get royalties from my book
sales my book sales are going through
the roof right now so i'm making
more information yeah there's two kinds
of discipline
there's internal self-discipline and
then there's external discipline so
right now if the world's kicking your
butt that's external
and if you're self-disciplined the
world's kissing your butt right now
it's up to you my poor dad my poor my
phd
father he always said to me he says you
know i'd be a rich man if i didn't have
you
kids and i said well you know dad
not my fault you had kids you know i
mean you know i just can't afford it
because i have kids
and the more he said that the angrier i
got
so when i went with my rich at age nine
you know he says well that's why your
man's poor
because he's lazy he thinks his phd is
going to carry him
he says everybody can say i don't have
money i can't afford it
he says that's why he's poor he's lazy
but my father kept going back to school
you know stanford university chicago
northwestern
he never learned any of this stuff they
still don't know it
because most teachers want a paycheck
pension and tenure they want job
security
so the mindset is different i took you
know three companies public
through toronto i mean through first
with vc
vancouver stock exchange and i thought i
might migrate to the toronto stock
exchange
why did i do that to learn learn to help
how to raise capital on public markets
now the average entrepreneur never does
that
you know they keep open their pizza shop
and they open two pieces of shops
and that's that's about it because
they're into just for the money
i wanted to learn something so i took my
first um
first was an oil company in portugal and
i took that public and everybody told me
there's no oil in portugal
and i found out the hard way they're
right there's no oil there
that company crashed and burned like a
airplane coming out of the sky
you know and then the next thing i
started a silver company in argentina
and we struck silver and we did very
well
yeah and then i started a gold company
in china
and the chinese took it so
was a priceless experience yeah aren't
you bitter i go
yeah but that's what i did it for you
understand that
i did it for that the tax department
which every country has taxes
determined they want to know what kind
of income do you work for
so when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent parent to the child
they say is go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income as you can see from this
diagram here
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here
and the first thing you pay is the
highest taxes because you worked for
money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money
they punish you for that they want you
to hire employees
or invest okay so earned income is what
they work for
the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if i buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand
i sell it for two hundred thousand
hundred thousand is capital gains
if i buy a stock for ten dollars and
sell it for twenty
the ten dollars of the capital gains
this is the second highest text
so the tax breaks that president trump
is working on today
is primarily for these guys here so
there are doctors lawyers
highly educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break but these
guys if you're active in stocks and that
kind of stuff of flipping houses
you get a break but what the really rich
work for
is
passive income and passive income
[Applause]
for me i have a business whether i work
or not
money comes in and you've seen me i'm
not here am i
no never never i've heard my right not
to be here
real estate i get milli every year
my wife and i can we add more real
estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this
we still get this but this is another
type of
income this here i'll get into is called
phantom income it's taxes i don't pay so
it's a little bit beyond most people's
minds
but let's say my tax bill is a hundred
thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break
that means fifty thousand in taxes i
don't have to pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government
it went back up here so that's what
financial education
does it teaches you about the financial
statement which is not taught in school
again they teach you fico scores which
is really fido scores
it was your total little dougie okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this
this is what they're teaching you to
work for now ironically
when you save money and you have a 401k
this is the kind of income so savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better is the saving money in
what he called it 401ks is good
in canada it's called rrsp in australia
called the superannuation
but this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because i'm an active investor
i don't buy
this because this is passive investors i
am active and
i'm professional in all of these areas
so i work for passive income which means
i'm not here
the check comes in the checks come in
every year
and you've seen kim and i and your
mother now
she's working on here and so your
mother's income keeps going up your
father's income keeps going up
and they don't have a job that's always
talking you want to find your soul
where is your soul you know what we'll
sit up you know
it's like when i was when i each time i
was going down
i wasn't flying for me i was flying for
my two
young gunners you know 19 year old boys
really with kids already
if i didn't do the best job possible
taking that aircraft into the ocean
though their their kids were fatherless
and i when i meet people who don't have
it in life
they don't really have that soul in them
the soul is there gonna be wrong it's
there
but you don't need it yet so today we're
aware
this i think we're going into a major
depression i hate to say that
but are you prepared for it i'm prepared
for it
you know i i wrote a book called rich
dad's prophecy
and i said the biggest stock market in
history was coming in 2016. so the
biggest crash in world history
came in march 2020. we're going into a
depression
you know hope not but i would say
there's a 60
chance for a depression now for somebody
with a soul and a spirit
it's the greatest opportunity in history
you know the world's changing i'm going
to get out of this thing
what is your definition of greatness
are you getting up every day
at my age you're going to worry about
that stuff you know i mean
i said my plan was to die at 72.
i almost died so many times i went down
three times in vietnam and
my days were numbered from the start
i've had open-heart surgery i've had
cancer i've had
pneumonia i've had malaria and so you
know what everybody talks about this
covet 19 i said i've been there
done that one you know but each one of
it inspired me to get healthier
and so this crisis should inspire people
to get wealthier or you can be a loser
mm-hmm so i don't know why i'm going
with that but it's just
all everything bad is good
and everything good will be bad so over
my lifetime
most of the projects i i've started i've
i've never had any money i like not
having money
because it forces me to think i get
creative
i have to educate myself i have to talk
to rich guys
how'd you do this how did you do that
how you do that and what has happened to
me
and i just turned 72 i've never needed
money
because if i need money i figure out how
to raise it
so today you guys have crowd funding and
all that i mean i don't know what that
stuff is
but it's easy to say i can't afford it
all the poor people say i can't afford
it all the poor people say well it's
taxed or rich
all the poor people are saying well give
me a free education
free food free schooling free manicures
free pedicures
there's laziness my opinion first word i
had to learn at the marin at the academy
mission mission is spiritual what's your
mission
and my mission has always been to serve
people
most people all they give up is making
money that's brewing people
that's called the federal reserve bank
wall street and all that i want nothing
to do with them
i just don't play their game but you
have to get smarter enough to play their
game
so when we so in 1989 when the world
wide web came up
and the berlin wall came down
simultaneously i thought that was
interesting
you know so that was it's another
transformation it's no
different than when you know let's say
i'm a king
i'm a king in portugal or something and
i got all my archers and my swords guys
and my spirit guys
and some entrepreneur drives it up there
with this cannon
it goes he just loads that cannon and
blows a guy's walls down you know
but that's kind of what's happening
today you know all the old guys standing
in their castle walls
and some entrepreneurs sitting there
pounding the crap out of them
so exactly when i was with steve burke
uh of nbc universal
he was saying the guys what what we're
doing the guys on social media
are kicking their butts right now they
don't know what to do you know they
can't stop us
so that's kind of what i'm talking about
the problem is the average person
because they went to school looking for
a job
they can't see what's going on they're
blind
so you know like and i think was on your
right your program you hold up a cell
phone
you got more power in that cell phone
than when i first went to the academy in
new york in 65 they had
full you know rooms blown sperry
computers and all that
you got more power in that cell phone
than that sperry computer at my school
in new york
and if you can't make money with that
cell phone
hang up the jock strap man so these are
the forwards income expense asset
liability and the last two words
are the words cash flow and that's why
the game is called
cash flow
and the secret to being rich is not a
college education
but can you control cash flow
and this is what cash flowing looks like
so this here i need this
income says asset liability again this
is you get a job and this was my poor
dad go to school get a job get your phd
and so this here is cash flow so the
income comes in
and it goes out this way first line of
expense is
so this is a poor person's cash flow
pattern
it's not how much money you make
most people you know they i don't care
if you have a phd or no school at all
they can't control the cash flowing out
through their expenses
and so that's why people like susie
orman say cut up your credit cards live
below your means
because you're a spendaholic so that's a
poor person
this is a middle-class person's cash
flow pattern
and this is where the house comes in
they
first thing you know most kids do when
they get pay raise or that
they buy themselves a bigger house
oh my house is an asset now who tells
you that your real estate agent of
course
yeah right because they they want to
give you this false sense of security
while you're getting screwed
exactly yeah but when you look at what
happens with a house a personal
i mean a personal resident something i
live in the money comes in and goes out
and this is middle class but it also
goes out through a mortgage
mortgage payments oh but i don't have a
mortgage you still have
taxes you still you know hawaii just
raised the property taxes on me which is
probably i'm going to sell i'm going to
get out of hawaii
but you have taxes and you have upkeep
so money is always flowing out
so that's why your house is not an asset
it's because it's taking money from your
pocket
so very simply said assets
put money in my pocket liabilities take
money from my pocket
and then this here is so i'm not saying
don't buy a house but here is
a house
and i started when i was
25 bought my first house
it was an apartment it was an investment
property
i didn't live in it i rented it out and
it put money in my pocket
so very simple the definition of asset
and liability is not the house of this
it's cash flow where is the cash flowing
so as a young person
and to all millennials or if you're old
financial intelligence is the ability to
control cash
flow this is the difference between rich
and poor
the people on this side
are always trying to save money
it makes no sense to save money because
after 1971
the united states took the dollar off
the gold standard
and the dollar became debt
so that people who are saving money are
the biggest losers of all
the people who are the biggest winners
are people who know how to use
debt to get rich see debt is money
after 1971 when nixon took the dollar
off the gold standard
money became debt and so the people who
are losers
are savers so as kenny says you put your
money in the bank as a saver
kenny goes in and borrows it out as a
debtor and we use that money to buy
millions of dollars worth of real estate
so kenny just went over a billion
dollars worth of real estate
using debt but most people say well i
can't
i can't do that because i don't have any
money
you don't have any money because lesson
number one says
the rich don't work for money
so we learn to use debt to create assets
and assets keep putting money in our
pocket
youtube has the best best teachers this
guy george gammon meant he's
great great teacher patrick david
fantastic teacher
you know cartoon fantastic teachers
so choose your teachers wisely that's
all
that's what i say because i have to
choose between my rich dad and my poor
dad
my poor dad phd poor helpless and
desperate
and that's what he wanted me to do when
i came back from vietnam was get my
master's degree at my phd
and fly for the airlines if i had done
that
you know my friends who flew for united
they're broke you know why they're broke
because wall street stole their pensions
you know
it's called an esa employee stock option
plan over my lifetime
i've raised hundreds of millions of
dollars
and it's because i don't have i didn't
have money as a young person
that i learned how to raise capital and
and
it's really quite simple you have to
find an asset
that's worth more than me you know if
they can't invest in me
because that's called slavery you know
they don't buy me you know
so what i do is you know i started off i
write about it in fake
i started off looking for this one
little piece of real estate
i found an excuse you know this one
bedroom one bath condominium on the
beach in maui
and i found an excuse for people to give
me the money
all i had to do is assure them i'd pay
them back
so my first deal was an infinite return
deal
i had no money in the deal because it
was 100 debt it was
an 18 000 condo you can't touch them for
that much anymore
but the economy was bad so i buy this
eighteen
thousand dollar condo the guy wanted ten
percent down you know
you don't need higher math
ten percent of eighteen thousand is how
much sports fans
eighteen hundred dollars i could have
used my money i had the money
but that would be too easy so it was
worth it from that point of view
and so that's talking to this one guys
well i have a private pilot's license
okay and then you know those guys know
it's called the big dog
he was like big dug in me i got a
private private license
i don't even have a license but i have
air metals
he didn't know what an air metal was you
know an air metal just meant how many
how many round trips did you take
into combat and came back alive i said
that's all i mean it doesn't mean i was
a hero
or anything because i wasn't you know
we're just happy to bring my crew back
alive that's all we cared about
but to get to that level of flying
is the same as investing and i think
that's what i really learned
is the dedication not to be to be the
best pilot but be the best that i could
be
and if i'm not the best that i can be
people die
and a lot of people it's okay to be
average
if you know what i mean but when you get
into that situation
when you're going in and out of those
combat zones i went down three times you
know
but i wouldn't be back today if i hadn't
practiced to be the best
and so when i go into the world of money
and investing that's i'm still not
you know i'm not zuckerberg or those
guys
but you still have to be the best you
want you can be
and that's how i can beat you know
investing in the stock market with
diversified stock of stock spots reach
over the etfs
if you're not willing to be the best
that you can be that's the best for you
you're an
average person nothing wrong with being
average
but there's something inside each of us
that wants to be the best at something
that one was reading your background i
think that's what you're
pushing people asking people what do you
want to be the best
at and i just love the marine corps i
hated it when i was in it
i tell you what they're not polite
but they demanded the best of it
so today i carry those traits i went to
military school and then i went to
you know five years of marine corps and
flying and all this
so when i hang out with my friends my
friends also want to be the best
and so in some of my books and things i
said look at the five people you spend
time with
you know if they're not striving to be
the best that's who you are too
a big lesson for you is that it's
nothing to do with the house the car the
student loan
it has to do with where's the cash
flowing if the cash is flowing
into your income statement into your
pocket
it's an asset it's good debt but if it's
taking money from your pocket it's
bad about that there's good debt and
that
if you're going to be successful like
whether you're an employee or
entrepreneur
you've got to control the direction of
your cash flow
first property there it was in maui
hawaii
in the 1970s i bought it with a credit
card
wow property was 18 thousand dollars my
first
prefer but i've taken several real
estate classes
and so i knew what to look for i found
this one property took a long time
when i found it i just broke up my
credit card and bought it
and i put 25 in my pocket the big
question is how much
is enough you know because i think the
reason kim and i are successful is we
always started small
we actually stay small kitchen table and
we do keep doing the same thing but we
don't ever
try to get big we got big but i think we
caught big by staying small
we did i mean our core group is very
small yeah and then we license out
so for those of you who think you have
to start some mega company or be
you know make millions of dollars that's
not really true the lesson is here you
gotta choose your teachers wisely
when the market crashed in 2008 guess
how much money i borrowed
a lot 300 million no way
from investors the banker how does that
how does that work because
interest rates were dropping and real
estate prices were going to the toilet
and when i walk into my banker this is
what rich dad poured out about this
airport
is about a financial statement income
statement balance sheet statement of
cash flow it's a book on accounting
people don't even know it's a book on
accounting so i walked into my bank with
my partner and had all this property
that was floating to the surface
and i say i'll take them off your hands
i just give give me the money to buy the
property wow
that's the honest 300 million give me
the money and i'll buy your properties
for you
that's crazy so it depends and this is
my whole thing i'm now
700 million almost a billion in debt
really you know why because i don't pay
any taxes the more debt i have the less
tax i pay
and the average guy goes how do you do
that because you have bad teachers
and so it's this whole thing that you
got to choose your teachers wisely
that's why i wrote the book fake fake
money fake teachers fake assets
i don't touch that garbage of wall
street puts out i don't have a 401k i
don't have stocks
visual funds etfs doesn't mean you
shouldn't but i don't need them
okay right and the other part is look
for young guys
the best teachers are not on colleges
the best teacher
are on youtube the best teachers are on
youtube
wake up i'm one of those kids who
doesn't like school
you know school is good for people who
like school
but here is my poor dad head of
education
phd on the governor's board of hawaii
and all this stuff and his kid me
and i'm flunking out of school because i
can't read i can't write
i said i couldn't read i couldn't write
i was bored out of my mind you know i
was just hey
so what i did instead was that's when i
met my rich dad was my best friend's
father
and he used these things called a game
see
games are the best teaching tools see
when i'm playing this game
this is how the rich taught their kids
battle strategies called chess
my rich dad taught me to be a rich man
playing monopoly we played monopoly
hour after hour after hour
you know the formula for great wealth of
monopoly is four greenhouses
one red hotel so today in arizona
i own 8 000 green hotel i mean
greenhouses
and several red hotels i just play
monopoly for real
so that's the power of a game because a
game engages me
mentally physically because i actually
have to move things
emotionally because when somebody knocks
me out
i better wake up you know i made a
mistake
and spiritually because it's spirit that
wins now if you just saw golden state
play the
play there you know everybody
i mean i love lebron james i love
cleveland
you know but one guy cannot take on a
team and
i think lebron scored 60 of all the
points
in assists and all that but a better
team beat them
so when you look at business business is
the same thing
but this is a team sport i have to have
good accountants good attorneys good
marketing guys good tech
guys great staff i have to have great
leaders
you know the trouble with most
entrepreneurs are self-employed
so they quit their job and you know in
america today the sba the small business
administration says there's 28
million small business owners
28 million 24 million are classified as
non-employers
remember their one-man team you know the
day like this guy said okay i'm gonna
take you on
are you crazy but that's what most
entrepreneurs are trying to do
because that's what they're taught to do
in school to be the rugged individual
you know in school i was very successful
as long as i could cooperate
at test time but in school cooperation
at test time is called cheating
in the real world the guys have the
biggest team win
so all i focus on is putting the best
team together
meanwhile a lot of time the a students
in school that the doctors and lawyers
are sitting there all by themselves
they're sitting ducks
but they're entrepreneurs they're
mindset
tactics strategy i went to military
school i'm a former marine
so i think like a military operation
which i love chess
so most most entrepreneurs you know they
have this job
okay i'm going to be an entrepreneur and
this guy says massacre
that's very good because they went to
school they learned to get a job and
they take tests on their own
they have to be the smartest that's like
the lebron james
i don't want to be the smartest guy in
my team but i want to have the best team
and that's why i win most of my games
that's great
i think like this and the doctors think
like this and
yeah i got you man for some reason
i get the sense i'm going to win you did
not have the rich dad in your life what
would you be doing today
that's hard to say if i didn't have my
rich dad because um
as a young kid starting at probably
about the age of five six seven eight
nine
i really wanted to be rich so i think
number one is desire you know and then
you
naturally seek your role models and
teachers and in my lifetime i've had
multiple rich dads
you know my rich dad was my best
friend's father starting the age of nine
and then today i still seek mentors and
wise men and wise women
because that's how you get wiser is by
hanging out with
smart people and i made the my usual
wise ass remark
only lazy people use their own money and
that's because
i have spent much of my life raising
capital you know today you have crowd
funding and all that stuff
but the reason i had to learn to raise
money was because i had no money
and so if you read rich dad poor dad
in there my my rich dad always said
never say
i can't afford it and it was my rich dad
and many of my teachers
subsequent to that this
lazy people always say i can't afford it
i don't have the money that's why
they're poor
they have a poor mindset so instead of
figuring out
how to raise money it's just really easy
to be a loser and i call it
losers it pisses them off
because we all have the power if we
wanted to
to not be poor if we learned how to
raise money
if you're poor right now
it was called look in the mirror that's
what i always said to me says
if you're looking in the mirror right
now and you see a loser
that's what you are you can't make money
in this economy
you better change your thinking you know
you know hindsight is 2020
as i said yes yes if you're looking you
know you don't have any money you don't
have a job
your boyfriend or girlfriend has left
you and uh
there goes well how did i get here
how did i get here there was a there was
a great book called uh
you know gulag archipelago by sulza
nathan
so he gets thrown in this in a um
concentration camp or a gulag in siberia
and he says how did i get here you know
how he got there
because he was a peacetime leader didn't
fight back
so people are being sold that they'll go
to school
get a job pay taxes
save money get out of debt
buy a house as a house as an asset and
invest for the long term
in a well-defined portfolio of stocks
bonds mutual funds and etfs
and i do none of that i don't know if
it's good news
except to be careful um
you know what changed my life was a book
like it did for many people it was this
book it was called the grunge of giants
and it's by dr r buckminster fuller and
grunt stands for gross
universal cash ice so when i was i think
in my 30s i went to study with fuller
you know he's most well known for the
geodesic dome and i first saw his
geodesic dome
in montreal canada expo 67 the world's
fair on the future
so my classmate from school in new york
we hitchhiked up to
um montreal just to see bucky's dome it
was a u.s pavilion and it blew me away
you know and um but we all have these
events and teachers in our lives
and so i think the good news is that
there's a teacher like you online now
the best teachers are on youtube not in
schools anymore
and um i think that's really the good
news is what we're doing
is the news what's happening in the news
today
is fake it's the old news this um
it's tragic this corona virus you know
like
i don't know if it's real i mean the
virus is real
but the media terrorism is frightening
so i've already been warned many times
to stay in my lane don't go into
medicine
don't go into this virus stay teaching
people with my little cash flow game
you know i'm talking about stay small or
will stomp on you
so i just remember back in 19 so i i
first went to the dome
in montreal at the world's fair in 67
and i studied the fuller in 1981 and i
started in
81 82 and 83 and he was predicting the
future
he told us what was coming and
as i've said many times many people it's
not what
i want to do i don't do what i love i
ask myself what does god want done and
what god wants done is that
his real education my opinion and his
financial education
and there is no real financial education
in our school systems and that's not a
mistake
so i um that was in 81 and 83.
i couldn't take it anymore i read i read
grunge of giants
and i understood it because my rich dad
kept saying
somebody's messing with us and every
time you say that you know you're a tin
hat guy you're aluminum hat you're a
conspiracy or a spaceship or an alien
guy and i'm just saying no i'm an
entrepreneur
at the time i was in rock and roll and
my first date with kim was to the police
you know and and she was out front
having a good time and i wasn't back
with the attorneys negotiating a
contract
so i'm not really a rock and roller but
i'm an entrepreneur
and at that time i said what does god
want done
not what i want to do i love rock and
roll
and what god wants done is financial
education that was my opinion but the
as that was in 83 so yesterday
you know and so i don't know if i'm if
that's what i'm supposed to do because
you'll never know
you'll never know what god once done so
i operate on faith
i don't know what the with people think
about money but that's what i get a lot
of is kind of this
well you know money's not spiritual i'm
just saying it's your attitudes you know
a person's attitude towards money i make
a lot of money
but i give a lot you know what i mean it
goes to
biblical principle the more you give the
more you receive
so when i meet somebody who's not
doesn't have any money
it just means they're not giving
something yeah you know so a lot of
times
there's people who would like more but
they're not giving anything
so they're like my poor dad and he
belonged to the labor unions and he
wanted to
work less and get paid more well that's
anti-religious to me yeah if you want to
get paid more
work more give more that's how i see it
so these guys have become small
entrepreneurs they wind up in
percent brackets
you can edit all that out right the
coffee okay
so you go there's a sixty percent
bracket so my objective was to get to
the i
and the b and the i so on the b side
when you're when you have 500 employees
or more you pay 20
in taxes so that's why you know when
we're here in new york city
when amazon was looking to move to new
york they were going to give them all
the tax breaks possible
now you're you're you know joe schmo the
uh computer programmer they don't give
any tax break at all
you know you pay the high taxes and then
the i quadrant is a professional
investor the insider the inside guy
and the number one ass is real estate
that's the game it's debt and taxes
so every time i make money in the b
quadrant as
a business owner i say 20 bracket i then
move my money into real estate
and i pay no taxes yeah and that's the
game so i get
the whole tax system of capitalism
is designed to make you richer but our
schools will never teach you that
which is the battle today between your
academics who are ease and s's for most
sakes
and then you have the bees in the eyes
their skill sets their mindsets their
beings
their spirits are different so like
you know when when they kick basils out
of here no problem he just moved
yeah so for an entrepreneur that wants
to
one day start the business and they
understand now because you hear
that the school system that they're
currently in is not going to provide
them that or their
let's say a parent is watching they know
that you know their student is going to
be
part of the stem field let's say what
should they do should they go out there
and
drop out like i did and try to start
their business and take that risk
what are the ways to transition off of
that well that's the reason i wrote rich
dad
poor dad and then the quadrant so it
gave guys like you kind of a road map
i mean there's so many different ways
you can make get there
and then the third book is rich dad's
guide to investing the i quadrant
see the i quadrant the key
and as a professional investor i
use the i quadrant to uh to analyze
businesses like i just invested an
education company and
somebody are you a trader what's wrong
with you why are you investing in
education
company i said who funds education
companies and they go i don't know
the government so that's why these uh
charter schools and all that they're
pretty good investments
because your source of income is the
government because you know the whole
constitution says every child must have
an education
so they might be teaching them garbage
but i like the source of funds
because you're on the other side i'm
only kidding because you're on the other
side of the table right yeah
what am i looking at you know if the
entrepreneur has no skills to say you
know i got a phd but i can't sell
i can't negotiate i don't have any
professional skills and all this
i don't care if a phd i'm not going to
invest in you but if you you say to me
the federal
is going to give you a million dollars a
month to teach kids suddenly i like you
a lot
because it's the federal government a
true true capitalist you're right
i'm not that mercenary i'm pretty close
i'm pretty close to that and then i'm
just going to invest that money in real
estate yep
yeah let's talk about money um
so we talked about this idea of the rich
mindset we understand
how broken the education model is
because it's
a lot of it as we mentioned modeled
backs to the 18th century
of prussia and in the factory system it
was
two what you're talking about had two
purposes one to train employees
and second to train soldiers people
would just do as they're told without
thinking
right was that because they were
fighting prussia and they realized how
efficient the soldiers were in the war
and they wanted to model after that well
they were taking farmers
right you see the whole thing with
agrarian industrial today technology
so back then they were trying to get
these farmers who are pretty independent
little guys
and they work for themselves so they're
trying to train them from farmers or
s-quadrants self-employed to employees
or soldiers right people who would do us
are told
right and the education system hasn't
been updated since that time because
it's actually gone backwards in my
opinion in what way
well they're misinforming and
miseducating
look the the biggest thing for an
entrepreneur is you've got to learn how
to make mistakes
and that the school punishes you for
making mistakes
second you have to operate in a team you
know everybody talks about team except
in school
if you take tests as a team you call it
cheaters
yeah so just those two minds constructs
the average guy goes out there afraid of
making a mistake and starts a business
and they make mistakes obviously
then they don't have a team gotcha
gotcha
the odds are stacked against them yeah
so i started my wife and i started with
a bookkeeper
why a bookkeeper because the number one
thing an entrepreneur must have is
accurate records
i've made so many guys show up and they
said where are your records they want me
to fund their company they don't have
any records
they have no numbers i said how do i
know if you're good or bad
well yeah man it's a good concept
we're doing a lot we're going to change
the world this is like a revolutionary
concept
we're good people yeah you know i have a
i have a master's in heart yeah we're
from the same city you know i know yeah
we grew up together if you're not doing
well if you're not thriving
today in this crisis then somebody
to your head somebody crawled upside
your butt and into your head and messed
with it
you know go to the school get a job card
taxes save money and get out of debt and
then invest for a long term in a
well-diversified portfolio stocks bonds
mutual funds and etfs
if you've done that you you're in big
trouble
so as you know if you don't change your
thoughts you don't change your life
and that's why i've been uh you know
i've been tweeting i know i'm so old i
don't know what twitter is
but anyway uh what was i talking about
oh i said go to youtube man there's some
the best teachers all right
too and they're not getting paid stupid
academic rates you know they don't have
tenure they just
most of them if they're a real teacher
they're doing really well today
you're doing well i'm doing well i would
listen to us
not that phony at harvard you know the
the peacetime leader
look i understand something i don't have
stocks bonus mutual funds you know why
why i could make up my own assets
i wrote this book called rich dad poured
31 million copies to make five dollars a
book you do the math on that one
i create my cash flow game i think i
make six six or seven dollars a game
in 50 languages i know how to sell you
go to school get a job you become an
employee but you learn nothing about
taxes then you become a little
entrepreneur you start your little
falafel shop business or whatever you
start right so
self-employed small business and then
you have big business
500 employees or more or i for an
investor
so tom how much tax do employees pay
well typically if they're making a good
salary and this is by the way the same
rates around the world typically it's
going to be about 40 percent
40 percent and after the attack the
trump tax cut did that change much
not much it didn't so if you're
you know oh i'm going to start my own
little business i'm going to you know
start my little
pizza shop or my my coffee shop how much
do these guys pay well
now it goes up because you're paying
both your share of the taxes
plus the employer share the the taxes
because you've got both sides
so now it goes up as high as 60 percent
so when you hear a young person an old
guy like me saying i'm going to start my
own business
they don't think about taxes do they no
and in fact this is the place where
people get
in trouble because over here this the
money is being taken out of your
paycheck
but here you're responsible for your
taxes and so what happens is that
you you go let's say you're successful
with your pizza shop right
all of a sudden tax time comes around oh
no i've spent all my money and i don't
have money to pay the taxes and people
go out of business real fast here
well it is surprising because a lot of
the millennials do want to start up
their own small little business right
and what they don't they're not aware of
is that they're going to be in the 60
tax bracket because taxes are your
single largest
expense so if you're going to start your
own business you got to be aware of
taxes here now big business as 500
employees or more how much do they pay
typically around the world about 20
percent
now why is it that big business people
pay less
than small business well basically the
government wants
the government wants us to do certain
things and they'll give us incentives if
if we do them and what they want out of
a big business
is they want employment so i want to
create employment because that creates
stability in the country
jobs jobs right and so the more jobs you
create
actually the more tax benefit you get
well look at amazon right now they're
looking at moving their company
how many tax benefits they're getting oh
my heavens they pay very very little tax
amazon does and and they pay you know
you talk about all those different
kinds of taxes not only they pay very
little income tax but they're also
paying very little
sales tax and employment taxes and all
those others because they're getting
benefits
from multiple types of government the
federal government
state government the city government is
that how is that how elon musk started
his battery factory in nevada well yeah
i mean elon musk he gets
huge research and development tax
benefits which by the way that's a tax
benefit that is tr
that is available in most countries more
than the us
right so if you're going to stay small i
mean it's a good place to start but
you're going to
really want to come over here eventually
and then the professional investors see
these guys are passive these guys invest
in stocks bonds mutual funds
they save money they're passive guys
they pay the highest taxes
but how much does a professional invest
like it's like shark tank
how much do these guys pay so they can
pay as little as zero percent
right they can actually completely
eliminate their tax
well most successful entrepreneurs have
gone blessed
right you know henry ford an old-time
entrepreneur he went bust five times
okay look look at steve jobs yeah his
own board fired him
yep you know bill gates was taken before
the supreme court
for monopolistic practices right even my
friend
donald trump went down a billion dollars
yeah i only went down a million
so the average person is so afraid of
those losses
they never get ahead because at school
they teach you if you make a mistake
or if you fail you're a failure but
that's not real life
a baby learns to walk by standing up and
falling down
standing up and falling down and our
school system punishes you for making
mistakes
that's why my poor dad an academic
was so unsuccessful he was terrified of
making mistakes
that's what bucky fuller said you must
trust your intuition
you know and it's called your gut
feeling a lot of the times
and scientists have just recently found
out there's actually brain material
in your gut that's why you get a bad
feeling and
that's kind of where intuition comes
from it's more from your gut rather than
your brain
and my intuition kind of changed because
i went to vietnam twice i was a good
marine
marine u.s marine pilot and all this i
was doing it for god
country in america you know all this
stuff and one day i was standing on the
battlefield in 1972 and i said
what am i doing here you know why am i
killing these people
i don't hate them they don't hate me and
that's when my life
you know you start me start waking up as
you grow older
so i learned to trust my intuition and
say what i had to say like
this book is about the future also
follows a futurist
so for me to write rich dad poor dad in
1997 nearly 20 years ago was about the
future
it wasn't about 1997. i always say to
people it's your mental skills how do
you control your thoughts
emotion because you know i have a bad
temper when i lose my temper nobody
likes me
so emotion and then it's
physical skills if i look like you know
a bag of dirt
and i'm not strong people pick up on
that health is important all that
and that's spiritual you know i don't
cheat on my wife
i don't cheat on my customers i don't
cheat people
i don't cut corners if i can't do
something i'll tell you up front if i
screw up i'll tell you
you know i mean i mean as as you and i
know there's a lot of scum out there
or entrepreneurs but they have bad
personal skills
they have bad responsibility skills
they're not legal ethical moral
spiritual
i'm trying to explain to you when they
tell you get out of debt
that's stupid because the money is debt
and the only way money gets out of debt
is via taxes
so all the people who work for money you
read rich dad poor dad what's lesson
number one
rich people don't work for money correct
money is
debt i use debt as money
and everybody thinks getting in debt is
bad well who told you that
i think the stock market is for losers
why would you put money in the stock
market when it's manipulated
that's what i think about so i'm always
watching the manipulation going on
behind the scenes
that's what my brain is focusing on all
the time
and i don't pay taxes the question is
how is it i don't pay taxes i can tell
you
that's not that's an important question
because most people are so
most romanians and most people in the
united states cheat on their taxes
because they hate taxes so much but you
don't have to cheat on taxes if you
understood how money was working
you think donald trump pays taxes no
nobody has seen his tax returns yeah i
know him he's my friend
we don't pay taxes that's the question
how is it we do that
that's an intelligent question the
reason you can't ask me this question
because you don't know how i do it
that's what i'm thinking about i'm
constantly thinking about how do i make
money
how do i serve more people how do i
create new businesses
make more money and pay less taxes and
serve more people
that's why i keep saying to the young
the millennials you know if they're a
pack of wimps
you know i meet millennials who are just
horrifyingly
weak snowflakes i call them you know
they go to college formats they're
taught
trigger events or whatever you know i
don't know what they say today but
they've got to have special rooms where
there's no
whatever i'm going holy mackerel
welcome to the real world you know and
there's other millennials who are as
tough as nails i mean this is the
biggest opportunity they've ever had
huge so it just depends upon what's
between this here and this year what's
in your heart i mean i read constantly
right now the book i'm reading is a
personal development book it's called
happiness morning
that's number one and the second book is
called the happiness the miracle morning
and
and happiness advantage one's written by
a harvard
teacher the happiness advantage
fantastic book
and the other book is miracle morning
written by an entrepreneur
and they say the same things but in
different ways so i read both of them
three times because they're so powerful
but i'm working on me you see there's no
the economy out there is just the
economy
if you think it's a bad economy it's
because your bad economy is here
if you think it's you know those jobs
are tough
that's because that's you and here as
any entrepreneur knows
it's always a good economy no matter
which way it's going i can almost make
some money it's always good it's always
opportunity
so i've got to protect the spirit or the
entrepreneurial mindset inside of me
so when the markets crash i make more
money
unfortunately for the average person
without financial education
the guy who invested for the long term
for job security their house is an asset
and all that stuff
they got wiped out that's what happened
in 2007 right here
they got wiped out by the crash and
others got richer by the crash
and that's the difference you wake up
tomorrow morning let's have some fun
with us
you you wake up tomorrow morning and
you're on the street and you have
nothing
you don't have a single contact
in your network all you have is the
knowledge
and experience that you've had
throughout your career
how do you build up from there well i've
been there
many times so it's no big deal you just
figure out what's needed and wanted you
go do it
you know people always kind of dump on
what he called it fast food industry
if i had to do it again i could work for
mcdonald's
and the reason i go work for mcdonald's
you know whether it's seven bucks an
hour or 15. i don't really care
i don't really like mcdonald's food but
they have the best business systems in
the world
you know how else can a company take
virtually non-college educated people
and build a fast food industry across
the world
and they have the best system so right
inside little mcdonald's
you can learn everything you need to
learn about business except for the
management side of it
so i just go work at mcdonald's so i can
learn even more
so i look at life as learning i'm
constantly learning you know i'm reading
constantly studying constantly
i spend my most of my time with
entrepreneurs
i don't spend my time with people who
complain about the economy
you know so nothing would really change
i just go back to being an entrepreneur
entrepreneurs have one thing in common
they keep going they'll change the rules
they'll reinvent the rules
you know they don't just take one answer
so a real entrepreneur it really
makes no difference which country you're
in that's my beliefs i'm not i
love that you know i mean it's just a
mindset
you know it's if you you mess with me
i'll find a way around it you know i
have a friend
he's a multi-multi-multi-family rich guy
from france
and you know france is as communistic as
it gets
75 top line for million dollar earners
yeah but that's why he lives here
so he he started buying
vineyards in napa and sonoma so he
went back to the french government and
says it's his
wine he says i want to ship my wine
in bulk to california
and the government says you can't do
that
so what french government said you can't
see yeah and here's a guy who's
i think is five generations you know
french wine guy
this guy is this guy is an entrepreneur
entrepreneur
he says okay i can't ship him in barrels
a guy goes yeah he says
okay i'll ship it in bottles
so he bottled all of his stuff it cost
him more money
but he still figured out how to do it i
mean and now he has
his wine with his california wine and
all this
and so he went back to the french
governments here try this
see if it's not better and so now
they're all confused because
he didn't break any rules so i'll say it
again
entrepreneur is a mindset first a skill
set
and rules and depending upon whether
you're employee or small business
the rules are different the mindsets are
different i am very shy
very very shy and i came back from
vietnam
and i could kill people but i couldn't
talk to people
[Music]
and one day i said to my when i decided
to follow my rich dad's footsteps i just
said to him
i want to be an entrepreneur he says you
got one problem i said what's that
you're shy i said what's wrong with
being shy
he says you gotta sell you gotta handle
rejection
number one skill can you handle
rejection
the answer is no i couldn't handle it so
i said i still don't want to learn how
to sell
so that this was in 1973 i was 25 years
old
and my rich dad said how's your love
life
so it sucks is he getting laid i said no
he says because you can't sell
guys got it so when i talk about what
skill
do you need when the ship hits the fan
you better start selling so i went to
work for xerox in 1974 so i can learn
how to sell
it took me four years and i was number
one
okay and today i'm a best-selling author
you know most
phd is telling me i can't write yes i
said i can't write but i can't sell
if you can't sell you don't make money
period
end the statement you know
just because you have a product doesn't
mean jack
but the important thing is you start i
don't care what product you start with
but you start you know i started off
with nylon wallets
success wiped me out you know we
couldn't sell couldn't sell
also that took off then i couldn't
finance i couldn't finance couldn't find
that because the
sales kept going through the roof now
trouble is i kept borrowing and i
couldn't sustain the sales
next lesson but that's how we learn
my last paycheck i still remember
clearly
it was one of the worst and the best
days of my life and i was in puerto rico
i was i was working for xerox and my
boss gave me my last it wasn't a
paycheck was a bonus check i think it
was about thirty thousand bucks
taxable so i call that so i got this
check and i went
oh look you know what means i was
excited
but i was also disturbed and so this
other guy comes up to me his name is
john
and john says to me says you're going to
be back i said why
he says because you're going to fail but
i've looked at him as a plug
few expletive words because that's what
he did he left xerox failed and came
back
i said look you failed and you come
came back but i'm gonna fail and i'm
never coming back
and that's the attitude do what i mean
yeah absolutely if you say well if i
fail i'll go back to mommy and daddy
then that's what you'll do so if you
fail that's when i became an
entrepreneur because i had no
money i had no money for years you know
i didn't have a paycheck
but that's what my rich dad encouraged
me to do he says when you're when you
don't have this paycheck
you get hungrier smarter and it's a test
of your character
when you become a crook we become
dishonest when you cheat and steal
or will you become a better human being
so really that's the benefit
of becoming an entrepreneur is you
really find out who you are
when you don't have anything if you're
an entrepreneur and you're going to be a
big entrepreneur
leadership skills and communication
skills are more important than a law
degree
so now i have another book that just
came out it's called the eight lessons
in military leadership
in the military i went to military
academy and all that
i like you know from day one you're
learning leadership you know day one at
the academy
i have to stand in front of 20 18 year
old kids and go
section 10 hut and naturally they're
they're gonna say
crew you you know so that's when you
learn to be a leader
now as you said to me when you first met
the troll with the military got a little
rough
i had a hard time when i came back from
vietnam and i went to work for xerox and
you know people don't like the idea of
columbus you know stuff like that every
other word is a curse word in a military
it's just an adjective
cannot do this you know
but they don't i'm gonna call my hr
person
i've already made some changes here you
know what i'm talking about
of course i don't know right no in
corporate america
in the military you can it's it's uh
yeah you have no choice
yeah you actually get promotions if you
do in the military
when i got called names i saw the guy
likes me
so that's why for all you guys are
military veterans you know you have
probably the number one skill to be an
entrepreneur
which is leadership the ability to
listen to not take it personally
and he'll still get the job done it is
the best training in the world
you know the saddest thing about leaving
the military was leaving the guys behind
her
they were some of the best in the world
and they were you know they weren't all
college graduates they were just
my gunners my mechanics you know all
this stuff the camaraderie is priceless
my camaraderie is priceless and so all i
did when i when i started the rich dad
company was to have
that same sense of teamwork inside
richton that's where there's no ranks
and all this stuff in this company
everybody gets to say what they want to
say people are free to do what they want
i stay out of their way
and we get the job done so the minus
touch is five things you got you must
remember
number one is the thumb which is
strength of character
you fail stand up don't lie don't cheat
don't just stand up own it
keep going on strength this is focus
you know the index finger this is where
i'm going and i talk about how i went to
flight schools
you know preparing to fly in vietnam you
know people are shooting at you still
going to stay focused on your target
even if you get killed in the process
this one everybody knows
this is what you stand for you know so
donald stands for the
absolute wealth and what i stand for is
very simple financial education
keep it simple you know teach people to
manage their money
so i stand for that and i don't ever get
off that track
the ring fingers for relationships if
you if
somebody is struggling financially be it
a company a country
or marriage it's because you have a bad
relationship
now the thing that donald and i always
say is that you can't do a good deal
with a bad partner and god knows i've
had some bad partners
and they're just incompetent but they
want to pretend they're smart
and then the little one is a little
finger every entrepreneur must do
something that nobody else does for
example in the united states walmart
their whole system of business is
designed
to give you the lowest price possible
everything whereas a little mom and pop
store they'll say well we put things on
sale that's not
the same thing fedex says overnight that
was their whole thing they built the
whole company around that little promise
domino's pizza in america was pizza in
less than 30 minutes so the entire
business was built around one simple
little promise
and those are the things that make
entrepreneurs extremely rich
or extremely poor if they don't have
those five is there a time to bail out
on a project though i mean when
i don't that's not in my vocabulary yeah
look
i have a i have an unfair advantage you
know i went to war
and at war i'm alive because other guys
died for me
when you see stuff like that you know
how can i quit
most guys are just wimps [ __ ] cowards
they don't have it
so they should they should get a job
what i want is
the attorney and the account who are
passionate about it being entrepreneurs
so my my guys right here in phoenix are
entrepreneurs
and my accountants are entrepreneurs
every time i hire the big name
corporate and law accounting firms
i have been grossly overpaid
and underserved because they're so used
to doing bigger things they don't have
time for a little guy like me
it's the same with bankers i'm looking
for a banker who loves being an
entrepreneur you know you got to have
this partnership with the bank you know
i i dump on the financial services
industry a lot
and they deserve to be dumped on but
you got to have one on your team you
know so my banker is the love of my life
because that's where i get my money from
the biggest thing for
most young people is that
our schools teach us to be ics into
independent contractors okay or
self-employed or
even if you're an employee you're still
an independent contractor as a job
and you do it by yourself you know i
think you know i think
i think much of much of the young world
is in the selfie world you know look at
me look at me
look at me whereas in my world it's a
team sport i'm a rugby player i go on
the field with a team
toughest meaning skies i know and so you
could be that you could be the a student
from princeton
but i go on the field with 15 tough men
kick your ass and so the average guy is
coming
out there you know like oh i got an a
i went to princeton i went to harvard
and corporate america comes out and they
go
boom so that's why when i talk to young
people i say look it's a team sport
so the first person i have is a
bookkeeper bookkeeper is the lowest paid
person on my team
but the most important right the
bookkeeper then keeps the accurate
records that my accountant can use
and my attorney can use and my banker
can use
that's the combination there and my
banker my attorney
and my accountant must work together as
a team
most people the bankers accountants and
attorneys don't work to those teams
because in school we're taught to take
our tests on our own
if you ask for help you're cheating in
my world it's called cooperation
and what i found with most smart people
they don't know how to cooperate
they don't know how to ask for help
because in their brains
that's cheating it means you're stupid
it means you're weak
it means you're stupid one of the things
i stress here at rich dab which i never
i didn't do
for much of the time was because once
kim and i had enough money
the question is what do you do next
and if kim and i had continued to work
for money i think i would have died
so when kim retired she was 37 and i was
47.
but just as we said on this with vantay
it's one of your primary objectives
especially today
is when do you plan to retire because
you know the idea of having a job and
waiting for your 401k
or your stock market to save you i think
you're going to be sadly disappointed
because
what i'm forcing is a massive crash
coming that's going to wipe out a lot of
people
and i'm coming up with a new book called
who stole my pension
and all these guys who think their
pension is safe
i think wall street has other ideas on
their pension here
so when i say the young people like you
guys i said you know plan
your retirement the day you start
working
you know when do you escape from the rat
rates that's the cash flow
i always say the number one skill of an
entrepreneur's ability to sell or
communicate
number one because sales equals
income so if your sales are down your
income's down
but it's not just selling your customer
you got to sell your employees
that's really tough you know and then
next is selling my investors so i'm
selling
investors i'm selling employees
and selling customers and i'm selling
myself
you know i got to talk myself into i
don't have the day
i don't have the pleasure of being down
entrepreneurs have got to be up
because if you're down employees know it
your customers know it the market knows
it
so number one is sales but when you look
at the big picture there's three things
an entrepreneur must learn
number one is pr and what you're talking
about is pr
the other day fox news interviewed me
to find out if i would endorse my friend
donald trump for president
you know how much that's worth you know
they they co-branded us
kiyosaki rich dad and trump
yeah that that's incredibly priceless
you know so getting pr is the number one
skill
under that is marketing and what
marketing does is like advertising
they want to set the customer up to get
ready to buy
oh yeah oh yeah i saw that key i had i
want to buy a kia i want to buy some
land you know i want to buy
this so the customer is now primed to
buy it that's marketing's job
then the last thing is a sale so if
you've done a really good job on pr
then you've done a great job on
marketing the sale is like that
you know they walk in they buy
but if you have no pr and you have no
marketing you have to pound
pound hard clothes well mr customer you
know
you know today's changing business
environment you know you should buy my
insurance and i'll
and people today hate sales pitches more
than ever before
so the number one sales job of a true
entrepreneur is develop your ability to
get pr
and i'll say it again most entrepreneurs
are not good at sales they're horrible
at marketing they have no idea what it
is
and they can't get any pr and so they
struggle
and again sales equals income so they
crash
if you want to stay small be the
smartest guy on the block
and that's why most accountants most
attorneys most doctors never get rich
is because they're too narrow you know
they're experts in toenail removal or
something you know what i mean
or my attorney a poor guy is an a
student but he knows jack about outside
of that
whereas i never had i'm not i flunked
out high school twice because i can't
write
it's iron if i'm right here today but
the reason i'm pretty good
is because in the military we're taught
to be generalists not specialist
so when i sit down with my team i have
accountants i have attorneys i have
media guys i have it guys i have graphic
designers and all this
so i operate as a team since i don't
know anything
so in in actuality being a great
entrepreneur means
i could be the laziest guy and i can
know the least
but i have to have a very smart team
which is the ring finger around me
so because i was never smart i had
respect for people who are
smart and a lot of times i meet a
students and they think they're the
smartest guys on planet earth
and that lack of respect will keep them
small and that's what most corporate
guys want to do
stay small you know you're going to
climb that corporate ladder you've got
to beat the other guys with a job and
it's all that stuff
it's not the way an entrepreneur really
works it's it's
corporate it's school system you know
you got to beat up for the grades you
got the best grades
i don't have to be the best but i have
to hang out with the best
what's your philosophy when it comes to
human resources how do you get the right
people
and then how do you keep the right
people it's the most important part of
business
you know that's why i went to military
school
and i went to i was a marine corps
the reason why i talked to military
veterans you probably have the most
important skill of
all because all we're trained to do
whether you're the general
or private you're taught to be leaders
it is a number one skill of an
entrepreneur is
people skills and leadership skills and
unfortunately
most people don't have it coming into so
when i do my talks to veterans and all
this stuff
i really want to encourage them you know
because they're pretty depressed because
they can't get you know
they're a walmart breeder which is a
good job
but they're afraid to take the leap into
entrepreneurship
so but military guys i don't care what
branch of service
just by the indoctrination process and
the survival rate whether they go to
combat or not
is that you're learning leadership
skills people skills you've got to have
that
you know whether whether you're a team
of one
you still have to deal your customers
and the good customers bad customers
lawsuits taxes government regulations
and all this
they're all people skills you know so
when somebody says to me
what do i need to learn i said boy you
better learn how to communicate pretty
quickly to people you don't like
and get them on your side you know how
to win friends and influence people
basic book the number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills
i always ask people what did you learn
about money in school
and for the answer for most people is
nothing they all learn economics balance
a checkbook
but that's really not money
and the reason they don't learn about
money is because the story of rich dad
poor dad
is my poor dad it was a phd which stands
for poor
helpless and desperate no it's a good
man
but as you know they don't learn much
about money and
my father knew nothing about money and
that's the problem
so we have all these academic elites you
know like obama and hillary and
those guys they run the country with no
financial education
is your advice to other entrepreneurs to
be searching for a big break
and if so how what's your advice on how
for them
for them to position themselves in the
best way to increase the chances to get
a big break
well again i said it might as well have
five things going for you
and when you're prepared it happens but
if you're not prepared it doesn't happen
for example
you know i was out here in aussie when
oprah called
i didn't start preparing when she called
you know i was prepared when she called
and my wife calls up and says hey oprah
called i go
so what she says well she wants you on a
program i go
so what because you know real men don't
watch oprah
you know post watch over not me you know
what i mean i don't watch oprah i didn't
know who she was
so my wife says get your butt home now
so i fly all the way from the bush way
inland from brisbane
to brisbane to phoenix to chicago and
i'm sitting on oprah
it's too late to practice you know so
but i have done
so many pr stunts you know stuff like
this here i've practiced practice
practice practice practice
and so when all the lights went on oh my
god
this is it it's too late to practice
and i learned that in the military as a
pilot in vietnam you know
i don't say well i should have i should
have stuck a little harder before i got
to vietnam
i got practice practice practice
practice practice because when that
little vietcong was shooting at me
you know there's only one guy going home
that day him or me
and that is too late to practice and
what happens for most entrepreneurs they
don't have the skills
they don't practice enough there's a
very good book called outliers
the story of success i think that's the
best book for entrepreneurs
because it talks how the beatles became
the beatles you know they played
more than any other band in history they
played almost for free in what frankfurt
or hamburg wherever they were
and the average person doesn't practice
enough the thing is you see when people
economies go up economies go down we
might go into a depression
worldwide like i said france is in very
big trouble
germany's okay england's in big trouble
china's in trouble
so if we go that we go to a worldwide
depression and it might take 10 years
you know
to come out of it but during these times
this is the best time i have made more
money in the last three years than ever
before in my life
you know i i bought five i bought five
golf courses last year
out of banks that's impressive yeah well
the
banks yeah donald bought 10.
they're giving them away
no one told me yeah but you have to know
how to operate them you know
you have to be an entrepreneur yeah so
the banks just call you up
and they say there was this one there
was five golf courses and one hotel
in the states in arizona yeah gulf mecca
you know
and this japanese company had it and
they asked me if i wanted to buy it
about five years ago for 260 million i
said
does it make sense you know it doesn't
make sense at 260 million
so they told me i didn't know what i was
doing they said i could buy
and then last just one year ago this
summer the
citibank called up and says you want
those golf courses
and they gave me the money to buy them
my attitude is this if you're going to
be a real entrepreneur
you're you have to be a lifelong learner
i am studying
learning constantly i never stop
and that's my competitive advantage but
also my
core advisor team we never stop together
you know i have my accountants my
attorneys my bankers and all that we
study together
that's what we do we get together we
don't play golf we don't drink beer
we study because study is the way you
win
but you have to know what you're
studying because you know what you put
in here garbage in garbage out right
another thing you have to be careful is
who is your who's your teacher who's
your mentor
you know i took golf lessons once at the
biltmore
and those most horrible golf lessons i
ever had
because that was a golfer the teacher
and i just did not get along
so they brought a new golf instructor in
and
i learned to love the game again you
know what i mean so as an entrepreneur
be very careful who your teacher is
because they can either kill your spirit
or increase your spirit a good teacher
will inspire you to learn more
a bad teacher will tell you you're
stupid and you should study more
i think most of your viewers out there
sitting inside their head
other words from their mother and father
go to school
get a job pay taxes
save money buy a house because it's an
asset
get out of debt yeah and invest in the
stock market
that creates poor people it's a hypnosis
train going through your brain
so when people say how do i change my
life when you change those words
i wouldn't go to school because you
learn nothing about money in school
ask i wouldn't get a job because if i
have a job i'm an employee
and then i'd pay taxes and i don't pay
taxes
and i don't save money and i use debt to
get rich
and i don't invest in the stock market
that's why i'm rich
and so the young people who are
listening right now are saying but
that's what my mom and dad said
but that's what mom and dad say all over
the world
so to the young people i just say
challenge or question
what you've been taught because from the
bible
i'm not religious yeah the word becomes
flesh
so if you say go to school he said but
i learned nothing about money get a job
you become an employee yeah if you're an
employee you work for money
i pay taxes then they tell you to save
money why would you save money when the
government's printing money
you know and get out of debt
well debt is money i use debt to get
rich most people use debt to get poor
and invest in the stock market i don't
invest in the stock market
so when you when you wonder why so many
people struggle financially because they
haven't challenged
the hypnosis the words go to school
get a job work hard
save money get paid taxes
until you question those hypnotic
trances
you don't change the question i ask you
is are you following the herd
you know the herd generally goes off the
cliff like a bunch of lemmings
and how many are doing what your mommy
and daddy told you what to do
go to school get a job invest in a
well-diversified portfolio
stocks bonds mutual funds and etfs is
that what you're doing
are you hoping that the next person
elected whether it's president trump or
one of the other candidates will save
the economy
well we have a very important show for
people like you
because this program is about you have
to do the exact
opposite of what everybody else is doing
because if you keep doing what
everybody's doing
i'm afraid everybody's going to go off
the cliff
that cliff is not too far away right now
as we know there's fewer and fewer jobs
you know american corporations say
they're hiring but they're not hiring in
america they're hiring overseas
but more than that is that the reason i
endorse network marketing
is most people are addicted to the
paycheck
and the paycheck is one of the most
sinister plots ever
pulled upon a human being if you need a
paycheck you've sold your
soul you know you sold your body
your mind your spirit and your emotions
you sit there in fear of losing your job
or
can i get a raise or you know will i get
promoted
i mean and then and then why would you
do that
and the other thing about really we
endorse network marketing we don't think
of it as a network marketing
we think of it as entrepreneur
development because if you need a
paycheck
this is not your business you know we
build businesses
so sometimes when kim and i do a deal we
may not receive a paycheck for five
six years you know and so these guys
come
am i going to get rich quick you know
and some people do i don't know you do
or not
but that is an employee get rich loser
mindset and so the thing that network
marketing does is really kind of cure
you
of that loser paycheck get rich quick
mentality
and actually build a business you know
we build
businesses but and that's how we're rich
but we didn't get rich quick
and i don't need a paycheck i never want
a paycheck
so that's kind of a revolutionary
thought to most people up there
who went to school to get good grades
and get a job you know they get a high
paying job and then
the higher paying job you you pay higher
taxes and you wonder why you never get
ahead
that's because you went to school to get
a job and a paycheck
you've got to get away from the paycheck
and sometimes it might take two
three years to get away from that and
that's what network marketing teaches
people
it's an entrepreneur's mindset it's an
entrepreneur's spirit
not a loser employee i need a paycheck
mentality
a big part of what makes a company
successful
is whether or not they have a brand
b-r-a-n-d almost misspelled it okay
and brand people think well it's the
communication you know
but a brand is more than that the reason
rich dad is so
valuable right now is because it is an
internationally known brand the same way
as trump is known as a brand and the
real question on a brand is not just
communication see
a brand makes it easier to sell when
somebody says rich dad they go oh i
think i heard of that or
i know what the guy stands for and all
this so what a brand really is
is the entire bi triangle if you're
going to create a brand
especially in a world that's overcrowded
with com advertising communication
the webs ipods print blogs i mean
there's so much competition now for a
person's time it really is more
important that you become a brand
so there's a shortcut communication like
if i say the word ferrari
you know you get a picture of something
in your mind it's a whole body effect
but if i said hyundy or kia
you know car they're probably just as
good a car but you get a whole different
emotional effect just by the brand name
so i'm not saying hyundai's are better
or worse than a ferrari but i'll pay
more for a ferrari than i will for a
hyundai
i don't own a hyundai by the way i own a
ferrari what does it mean it's a
shortcut communication
like if i say the word apple you know
some people think of compute computers
and some people think of red apple
but for the guys like me who i'm an
apple fanatic you know the brand means a
lot to me i love steve jobs he's one of
the best entrepreneurs in the world
right now
and if i say the word marine corps
marine corps is a brand it communicates
everything the mission the team the
leadership
the style the message and the marines
have a saying we're only looking for a
few good men
and women that means we just don't want
to be like the army we have to position
ourselves away from the army the air
force and the coast guard and the navy
so brands are so vitally important as a
communication tool
especially in today's over communicated
to world
there are more people competing for your
customers mind
their time you know how many blogs can
you read how many magazines can you read
how many television sets can read
how many games can you play and all this
so today if you're going to be an
entrepreneur
it becomes more and more important that
you become a brand
there are people who want to go into
real estate but they have the they have
the negative midas touch
everything they turn they touch turns
are [ __ ] you know it doesn't turn to
gold
and then no matter what piece of real
estate or another what stock they go
into they have a loser's mentality
and that's why i don't hang out with
losers well i'm a good hard working
person
i say no but you're a laborer you're not
an investor you don't understand me
but i'm a good person i go to church
every sunday i work hard
i say yeah but you're still a loser it
doesn't mean you're a bad person does
that make sense you guys here
you're a loser you're a financial loser
that's what it means it doesn't mean i
don't want a bad partner
i only became an entrepreneur because it
was the greatest
challenge i could take on as far as my
personal education personal development
yeah and it wasn't to make money you
know and as i said my first business was
a nylon and velcro surfer wallet
business and the mistake i made i was
successful
and we grew internationally so fast i
just couldn't
finance my success and so i started
borrowing money and which was good i
started to
learn how to raise capital i learned i
learned how to negotiating um you know
in the reason i was in korea fighting
taekwondo was i was out there
negotiating anyway for production
because we were manufacturing in hawaii
where the cost of manufacturing was too
too high sure so i had to fly to korea
and taiwan to negotiate manufacturing
i tell you man you're not stupid until
you're negotiating against koreans and
taiwanese man those guys had me coming
and going up one side and down the other
but that's what i did it for you know
what i mean is to learn
and to learn to finance learn how to
factor you know how to
how to ship and then factor my inventory
and all this stuff and i learned
so much as i was going broke
successfully going broke
and so when i explained to young people
that's what i did it for that so that's
how you get smarter
but in this academic culture you know
we're just talking about jordan peterson
how he yeah
he rails up against academics well the
academic culture the person who makes
the most mistakes is a stupid person
but an entrepreneur the person that
makes the most mistakes and learns from
them is the smart
is the rich person so i always tell
young entrepreneurs it's not
money will never make you rich you know
it's your experience your how much you
learn the mistakes you make the people
you make
and all of those horrible experiences
are all good experiences if you
learn from them sure and that's the
attitudinal difference of an
entrepreneur most guys are small
business guys they're not entrepreneurs
you know they open a pizza shop to make
money and they get stuck in that pizza
shop forever you know
well that's not me and the subject of
entrepreneur
is a massive subject so he got a drug
dealer
peddling drugs he's also an entrepreneur
as his jeff bezos
running the biggest product pushing
country in the company in the whole
world
they're both entrepreneurs but the gap
between the drug dealer and bazels
massive so when i speak to young people
so what kind of entrepreneur you want to
be
and if you're just here to make money
since you can do that but it's not
exciting
people trying to do good by educating
outside of the traditional school system
where they're i think they're more
limited
correct and that's why i created the
cash flow board game is because i
learned about
i learned about money playing monopoly
yeah i learned more about
life playing monopoly than i did in four
years of college
yeah i went to a really good school you
know the best schools in the world
u.s merchant academy that came out a
rich man
but it didn't teach me much about money
i was only a high paid employee
i just think about the economy business
okay world affairs
i i want to my job is to make
complex financial systems simple enough
so the average person can understand it
that is extremely difficult
because most people are brainwashed when
it comes to money
go to school get a job
work hard pay your taxes
save money get out of debt buy a house
and invest in a stock market everybody
who follows that program
has been brainwashed i don't even care
about money i make a lot of money
because i understand the system
i would never go to school get a job
work hard save money get out of debt
buy a house and invest in a stock market
i do everything
exactly opposite it is insane the the
several things that i i find
one more time second book cash flow
quadrant es
on the right side is b and i and that's
again that's where
guys like mark cuban and damon johns
come from
you know they're they're professional
investors they acquire companies
finance companies they have what's
called family offices
not not home businesses or family home
offices
they're family offices so i have a
family office so when i when i was a
young man
my rich dad said to me someday you want
a family office
i said what does that mean i got an
office he goes no no no no
it's we have a whole team of people
moving your money for you because you
got so much money coming in
say too much money is a problem also
because you got to keep moving it
so i have a family office and that was
part of the whole process
of becoming rich was so i could learn to
have a family office
and the average guy is a 401k why am i
kicking his butt i don't care if he went
to harvard
i'll kick his butt up one side and down
the other
making millions not paying taxes but
keep moving my money well i always say
quit your job
but that's not you know i don't have a
job i never i've only had one job
and i never wanted a job after that
because i had to be hungry
not to say you know but we're all
different we're humans we're different
beings
if i share this diagram here you know
this it's why i created my
cash flow board game because we have
four
different intelligences we have mental
intelligence we have i don't know what
that one is
spastology you probably have very good
physical to make you know
football and all that yeah emotional
intelligence but spiritual intelligence
so i went to military school in new york
the first thing is spiritual
you know i become a marine that's
spiritual yeah
you know what i mean because you're
putting your life on the freaking line
yeah you know so nazim talib you know
wrote the book the black swan
he also wrote uh anti-fragile he since
there's three kinds of people in the
world
there's fragile and that's what our
school systems are putting out
fragile 1b snowflakes and that's your
choice you want to be that way
have a good life the second type is that
sauce
are fragile like a champagne flute yeah
you hit it at the shatters
then the second one is called robust and
a robust person
is like the rock you know you can pound
on them
dump on home yeah they
take it but that's all they do
they take it and that anti-fragile is
somebody
like you where they pound the crap out
of you
and you get smarter and better because
so i love nazim talent you know a lot of
people call them dr doom
but the way i look at this whole thing
this economist
we're probably going into depression you
know we're not going to get out of this
really oh yeah and so the thing is
is this good for you or bad for you i'm
looking forward to it you know the last
the last crush was 2008
and i made more money in 2008 than in my
whole life
so this one here 2 000 you know what is
20 20.
i'm going to get even richer but i'm
going to get poor
and if they're baby boomers they're
going to blame it on this coronavirus oh
my health you know that
hey hit the road put on some running
shoes change your diet get some sunlight
you know get healthy don't get don't be
a wimp
but oh no i'm so afraid of dying i'm
going you're already dead you don't even
know it yet
you know the marine corps you know in
the marine corps
we usually call them corpse people right
corpse not core
yeah of course no a corpse a corpse man
is a person who's dead but doesn't know
it
wow they're so afraid of dying they're
already dead
yeah it's about taking action taking
control of your life taking control of
your health your finances everything
this is the best time to be alive right
now what should
the people understand about this way of
living because
we cannot all be entrepreneurs some
people need to get some
jobs or should we all try and look at
how we can change our lives in in the
way
you show it in your books and your
keynotes
talk to the person
it's up to the person it's a free free
choice you want to be an employee
you choose to be an employee you want to
be an entrepreneur you choose to be an
entrepreneur but you've got to study
two different people what you have to
study is different
mentally emotionally and spiritually
they're different people an entrepreneur
is extremely different than an employee
but it's a different study the trouble
is our school system trains us to be
employees
go to school get a job work hard save
money pay your taxes get out of debt
and invest in the stock market that
makes you poor the biggest thing for an
entrepreneur
is you've got to learn how to make
mistakes
and they school punishes you making
mistakes
second you have to operate in a team you
know everybody talks about team except
in school
if you take tests as a team you call it
cheaters
yeah so just those two minds constructs
the average guy goes out there afraid of
making a mistake and starts a business
and they make mistakes obviously
then they don't have a team now i've got
a special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following will jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you rule number one and rich dad
poorness of rich don't work for money
most people miss that one but that goes
back to 1971 when nixon took us out the
gold standard
yeah and money became fake money yeah so
anyway um
my rich chip was preparing me to think
about how can i make money without
making
without money and the way i do it i
create an
asset like a book i'm not saying write
books because that's
a tough industry but i write a book
today
i sell 50 licenses to 50 different
languages
and i i collect royalties for years the
long tail
yeah so my money just keeps coming in
from with that i
i borrow so let's say i make ten dollars
in a book
i'll borrow fifty dollars to invest in
real estate
i step up my basis for depreciation
advertising and uh appreciation
good job that's financial education yeah
yeah that garbage they teach you about
invest for the long term of the stock
market why would i do that
when i can make up my own assets yeah
you know that's what entrepreneurs do
every entrepreneur should be making up
their own assets and staying out of the
stock market that's my point of view but
can everybody do it no of course not
sure but i've screwed up enough times to
prove i can do it
and my accountant will back me up yeah
the guy is an idiot
but he does create assets if you want to
learn how to get rich in network
marketing like robert kiyosaki check out
the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there let me tell you
why i endorse network marketing a way i
call it the power
of it the reason for it is as a
as an entrepreneur